you make a lot of money you know keeping
people kind of you know giving them
pills and getting them surgeries and all
that stuff there's a good aspect to you
know helping people but all these days
there's there's economic aspects to it
and also you know there's there's
conflict of interest sometimes because
you know the goal of a medical
professional the goal of a doctor is
supposed to be too to help the patients
to get wellness to get healthy you know
to get out of the issues that they have
and to maintain a good healthy body and
you know you're able to function but
there's that conflict between you know
what you're a surgeon you know I want to
upgrade my Mercedes you know I want the
I want the latest model if I don't give
this guy surgery I'm gonna be making you
know 10,000 20,000 less just add a
little extra surgery in there you know I
can make an extra 20 K through 10k
whatever it is little tiny thing you
know someone's going to birth maybe the
baby would have come on naturally just
go straight to see section just so you
know we recommend you just go straight
to see section and the person's like
well you know the guy in the white lab
coat said that so we should go ahead and
do it you can make some extra money and
that's just part of human nature so i
think that the medical industry or them
even the medical experts they're not
they're not exempt from these type of
you know human frailties human
weaknesses and that's concerning that's
very concerned so we can say we
shouldn't be naive we shouldn't really
nice we we need to question we
absolutely have to question and that's
as something that were taught as muslims
you were taught in islam that you know
what should always be searching for the
truth in everything you know so god
created us with the mind for a reason
right and we're supposed to try and find
the truth wherever that truth lies yeah
she'd be willing and open to listen and
to kind of hear away what's going on
kind of especially when you when you
when a mistake has been made in the past
you know the Prophet peace be upon him
he actually said that a believer is not
bitten from the same hole twice so once
you find out that you know what if
there's a misdiagnosis or your doctor
did something that wasn't needed to be
done are you learning the past that you
know what some medical information that
was mainstream it was taught this is
absolute fact and then it's completely
overturned 10 years later 20 years later
like I can't believe they everyone
bought into that idea
that's crazy they they thought that this
was correct you have to be a little bit
more skeptical so that you're not bitten
from that same hole twice you got to
learn your lesson yeah that makes sense
that's where we're taught be true
seekers why is modern medicine practice
the way its practice with such a heavy
emphasis on pharmaceutical drugs and
surgical procedures and and and other
practices that people can't do for
themselves and it's all about what the
doctor does for you what the doctor does
to you but they really don't give any
any attention to empowering people to
help you better know how to take care of
yourself now there are some exceptions
there are what I call some real doctors
some real doctors who do that some real
doctors who actually do teach patients
how to improve their health by improving
the nutrition in the and other aspects
of self-care but that's not what
dominates unfortunately what dominates
our medical doctors who no matter what
your problem is no matter what's going
on here's the solution it's a
prescription or it's a series of
prescription drugs and there's a place
for that but there's no drug that was
ever developed that addresses the cause
of any health problem not even
antibiotics you because some people
might say well antibiotics address the
cause of problem because they directly
kill germs that can cause infection but
wait a second human beings have an
immune system your immune system is
supposed to be the main the main
protection against any type of infection
so when someone gets an infection
consider that their immune system was
too weak to do what it needed to do the
immune system got compromised somehow
and antibiotics can certainly kill germs
and in and clear up an infection in the
short run but antibiotics also they have
they have some pretty serious other
effects they can damage your
intestinal ecology kill off friendly
bacteria in your in your intestines and
set you up for all kinds of intestinal
problems everything from from a
condition known as candidiasis which is
intestinal yeast and then fungus
overgrowth which causes problems with
the digestive distress and in
antibiotics also they not only they not
only have this adverse effect and
killing the probiotic friendly bacteria
that everybody needs for healthy
digestive and intestinal health they
also can weaken your own immune system
response you know in my years at dr.
mercola clinic we had so many patients
come there who had as their history in
their history recurrent infections
respiratory bladder sinus infections re
constantly treated with antibiotics and
this would go on for years with some
people you know the antibiotics we're
not addressing the cause of their
problems because it was only they take
the antibiotics to clear up the
infection and then you know month later
two months later they get another
infection treated with more antibiotics
consider that this is not medical
science this is a business model